[Aplausos]
la canciller alemana angela merkel ha
entrega oficialmente al cargo a su
sucesor olaf scholz dos meses después de
que el partido socialdemócrata ganaran
las elecciones parlamentarias el nuevo
canciller debe trabajar con su gobierno
de coalición
esta alianza formada por los
socialdemócratas los verdes y los
liberales es la primera agrupación de
este tipo a nivel nacional y mantener el
trío unido requerirá un delicado acto de
equilibrio
de verdad sachs ter sí la buena
cooperación que funcionó durante la
formación del gobierno continúa será un
momento muy bueno para las tareas que se
avecinan a principios de 2020
formó parte del gobierno entre 2007 y
2009 y como ministro de trabajo de
merkel durante la crisis financiera
mundial es conocido por un estilo aún
más sobrio que el de la canciller
saliente
básicamente scholtz es más partidario de
una vía moderada de un estilo de
gobierno pragmático a tu asistente del
ministro crisis la coalición aspira a
una más verde y justa i parassols y los
retos para la próxima década empiezan
con el cambio climático el lunes se dio
a conocer el primer gabinete equilibrado
en cuanto a género del país
ahora tenemos que dar vida a esta
coalición con previsión pragmatismo y
sobre todo con mucha pasión no por
nosotros como gobierno o partido sino
por la gente de este país en toda su
diversidad mayores y jóvenes nacidos
aquí o en otros lugares en enviar a fire
fire of alex wong sin embargo el primer
gran reto al que se enfrenta olaf scholz
es la situación sanitaria que
actualmente constituye una crisis en
alemania